[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo hay conmoción entre la
población lgp y en colombia por una
serie de asesinatos y ataques a
integrantes de la comunidad de acuerdo
con las autoridades locales varias de
las víctimas mortales fueron contactadas
a través de granger la red social de
citas para personas de orientación
sexual diversa casos como estos se han
venido registrando en todo el mundo al
menos desde la última década por lo que
han surgido una serie de
cuestionamientos como qué
responsabilidad tienen las plataformas
de este tipo si es recomendable
seguirlas usando y de ser así qué
aspectos de seguridad hay que tener en
cuenta hablamos con expertos empezamos
seis personas de la comunidad del gp y
han sido asesinadas en lo que va del año
en medellín-colombia y lo que preocupa a
esta población es que según las
autoridades en varios de estos casos los
atacantes han llegado a sus víctimas a
través de granier la famosa aplicación
de citas para personas de orientación
sexual diversa si bien la cifra es
alarmante la situación lamentablemente
no es nueva hechos como estos se han
presentado de manera repetitiva en todo
el mundo el caso más sonado es el del
británico stephen port apodado el
asesino de grinder y quien fue condenado
a cadena perpetua en reino unido- por el
asesinato de cuatro jóvenes y por
cometer múltiples abusos entre 2014 y
2015 contactando a sus víctimas a través
de diversas plataformas digitales para
hombres tanto hombres como mujeres han
sido víctimas de algún tipo de agresión
por parte de personas que conocieron a
través de aplicaciones de citas entonces
debería dejarse de usar estas
plataformas o simplemente hay que ser
más cuidadosos a la hora de usarlas se
lo preguntamos a alexander díaz abogado
especialista en ciberdefensa y
protección de datos e internet todo es
peligroso e independientemente de cuál
sea el propósito y para este caso no es
la dirección más cuando las personas no
tienen descuidados debidos para tener
una relación cualquiera que sea su nivel
de acercamientos yo no paso sino ninguna
plataforma de esta naturaleza
con estos fines de encuentros
anónimos porque
[Música]
tiene un riesgo muy alto y yo como como
experto en ciberseguridad pues yo no
puedo invitar a las personas a que
pongan en riesgo su seguridad y muchas
de estas plataformas ponen en riesgo su
seguridad por su parte miguel rueda
psicólogo y director de la organización
lgtb tipping consultores en bogotá
colombia cree que hay que ser muy
cuidadosos pero también reconoce que
estas plataformas pueden llegar a ser
muy peligrosas especialmente para
personas de orientación sexual diversa
que a menudo son objetivos de crímenes
de odio además le consultamos qué grado
de responsabilidad tienen las
aplicaciones cuando se presentan estos
casos es una situación de
corresponsabilidad cierto entiendo la
importancia de las redes y la
responsabilidad en las redes en donde
hay digamos ellos hacen eso
y ofrecen este servicio dan los tips de
seguridad es corresponsabilidad de
usuarios usuarias también llevar a cabo
esa responsabilidad setera etcétera pero
en el momento en que hay consecuencias
de este nivel de gravedad todo el mundo
tiene que asumir la responsabilidad y
serán las autoridades pertinentes las
que digan qué tipo de responsabilidad
técnicas única para todo está
relacionado y mucho más en estos lugares
de estas aplicaciones digamos en estos
lugares virtuales en donde
están muy ligados a las citas para por
ejemplo poder tener sexo casual y en ese
sentido se culpabiliza aún más por el
hecho del sexo casual de alguna manera
orientación sexual e identidad de género
en el caso de las mujeres
específicamente por el género fueran
sexo se les señale se les culpabiliza
por qué se lo buscaron cosa que nunca es
cierta la culpa nunca es de la víctima
siempre es del 'big mac' france24
contacto a granger y le preguntó
directamente por los recientes casos que
han ocurrido en colombia y sobre todo
que están haciendo al respecto un
portavoz de la empresa respondió que se
toma muy en serio la privacidad y la
seguridad de sus usuarios y que por ello
hay en su página una guía de según y
consejos para usar la aplicación esto
dijeron a través de un comunicado
alentamos a los usuarios a tener cuidado
al interactuar con personas que no
conocen alentamos a nuestros usuarios a
denunciar comportamientos inapropiados o
ilegales ya sea dentro de la aplicación
o directamente por correo electrónico a
health granger puntocom y hacer
denuncias penales a las autoridades
locales y en estos casos trabajamos
directamente con las fuerzas del orden
público según corresponda y es que
aunque grandeur brinda una serie de tips
de seguridad lo cierto es que en su
aplicación existen distintas falencias y
si vamos del experimento y nos
encontramos con esto primero permitió
registrarnos con una dirección de correo
electrónico que no existe aunque la app
si solicita un número de teléfono para
validar el registro entre sus
recomendaciones sugiere que si usted no
se siente cómodo usando una foto de
rostro para su perfil considere una foto
que lo represente de otra manera
buscamos una imagen genérica en internet
y ésta fue aprobada sin ningún problema
la plataforma también permite vincular
las redes sociales de una persona en
este caso usamos la cuenta de instagram
de grandeur como si ésta perteneciera al
perfil acabamos de crear y no presentó
ningún inconveniente ya ha habido quejas
de usuarios que denuncian que personas
desconocidas han vinculado sus cuentas
personales a grandeur sin su
consentimiento miguel rueda también
ofreció una serie de tips para tener en
cuenta a la hora de usar este tipo de
aplicaciones muchas veces la gente se
siente un poco avergonzada por hacer lo
que está haciendo conseguirse alguien
por una de estas aplicaciones necesitas
y no cuenta a dónde va ni con quién está
lo importante es que por lo al menos una
persona de confianza sepa a dónde va a
ir con quién va a estar el nombre de la
persona me tomaré un pantallazo al
teléfono del perfil de la persona
pedirle otras redes sociales distintas
hablar a la que estamos usando con esa
persona en ese momento todas todos y
todos somos absolutamente libres de
gozar de nuestra sexualidad de nuestro
erotismo como queramos nadie bajo
ninguna circunstancia puede llegar a
alentarlos porque no le parece lo que
estamos haciendo nosotros y nuestra
manera de establecer vínculos afectivos
establecer vínculos eróticos hasta aquí
revista digital recuerda que se quiere
repetir esta u otra emisión de nuestro
programa hacer a través de nuestra
página web www punto 4 punto com
[Música]